guys it's kif
it's GQ sneakers and suits I feel like
we have some Authority I believe that
it's been done a certain way for a long
time and not to say that that's not the
proper way of doing it but I believe
that there's a new more progressive way
of doing it your pants have got to be
slim yeah for sure so I don't like the
break in the pant
I like a slimmer leg and a more tapered
fit I'm gonna go with a clay Ellington
okay it's a shoe that they've had in
their line for a minute one of those
classic shoes that really look good with
a suit just cuz of how tapered the toe
is all black up or a white sole really
comfortable and that's something I feel
like it's overlooked a lot with those
that are shopping for shoes for a suit
because you don't want to go home and
start you know placing baddies in your
feet I'm sort of going the retro way you
1970 all black Chuck Taylor with the
skinny pair of pants you know the break
can come down a little bit over the high
top it's kind of like I'm it makes me
think of The Strokes can't go wrong with
a pair 1970s all black with a suit I
feel like it's a Stephanie a great
choice let's take them to outer space
the future of shoes with a suit in my
opinion y3 has done a great job in
creating the sleek boost models right
it's a knitted upper it's very narrow
you know other than a converse or vans
or Stan Smith this is like the new
generation of what to wear with a suit
it's very sleek mostly neoprene and if
you want to talk about comfort I mean
you'll right you'll break that to me so
that it's like wearing socks on the
dance floor that's right Keith and GQ
sneakers with suits they don't listen to
us when they can listen to unclear guys
if you have any questions for GQ any
style questions leave them in the
comments try not to destroy us in the
comments section though we're working
hard here yeah we're working hard take
it easy on us all right all right we'll
see you soon thanks